I'm going to talk about post-transplant therapy with ibertamide and daratumumab.
These are my disclosures.
And just to review, ibertamide is a member of a new class of immunomodulatory drugs called
CellMods, targeting the cereblon-E3 ligase complex.
Normally, this is a normal part of protein degradation.
And in the absence of IMIDs or CellMods, there's a certain cache of client proteins,
substrates that get dragged to the proteasome and degraded.
And in the presence of IMIDs or CellMods, there's a change in the substrate profile
that's bound, which includes icorose and aolose, which are, as we know, important plasma cell
survival proteins.
And the relative degree to which these survival proteins can be degraded are significantly
higher with the CellMods than with IMIDs.
And iber, for instance, compared to lenalidomide and pomalidomide, about 20 times more so.
So this has been not just shown preclinically, but we know that this translates into clinical
activity.
And that about a third of IMID refractory patients can respond to the combination of
iberdomide and dexamethasone.
And we're going to hear in the next talk, I'm not going to go through this slide, but
we're going to hear about a talk comparing iberdomide to lenalidomide directly as post-transplant
maintenance therapy.
I'm, I just want to also just further, like, the rationale for including daratumumab in
the drug.
And I think the rationale for including daratumumab as part of the combination has to do with
the immune modulation that these drugs promote their activity on T cells and NK cell activation
and expansion directly feeds into the, the, the mechanistic activity of daratumumab.
And so there, there is strong rationale for combining these agents together.
So we are in the midst of doing a study called the IBEX trial at the U.S. Department of Health.
At the Kermanos Cancer Institute with our friends and colleagues at Indiana University, this
is using iberdomide and daratumumab as post-transplant maintenance in patients who have had
daratumumab containing induction therapy prior to transplant.
Originally, the study, the primary endpoint of this study was conversion from MRD positivity
to MRD negativity.
So the original patients enrolled were all MRD positive at the end of transplants.
We modified the, you know, as our, as our thinking about best use and most, you know,
informative MRD results has evolved.
We changed the primary endpoint to sustained MRD negativity, which no longer requires the
patients to be MRD positive at enrollment.
And so currently we're taking all comers as long as they've been DARA exposed.
The starting dose of iberdomide is 0.75 milligrams daily for 21 out of every 28 days.
And the daratumumab schedule in this study was designed intentionally to very closely
mimic the DARA schedule of the dramatic study because I think many of us are anticipating
that after the dramatic study results come out that lenalidomide and daratumumab may be
the standard to which future maintenance is compared, right?
Another key endpoint of this study is safety and the design of the safety analysis is such
that it will permit us to report on some interim results, including safety at ASH this year
and spoiler alert, as you might guess, neutropenia and, you know, myelosuppression is the main
thing that we're seeing early on, especially during the more intensive part of the DARA
dosing.
And ultimately we'll be doing some immune profiling as well.
This is not the only study looking at iberdomide in combination with CD38 antibodies as maintenance
therapy yesterday or a couple of days ago, we heard about the MIDAS study, which in patients
who are MRD positive included iber-ISA maintenance following transplants.
We also have another study comparing RVD, ISA-RVD and ISA-Iberdomide.
And I think those are both a way out in terms of hearing, you know, any real information
about the results of the maintenance strategy, but we probably will be hearing something
at ASH this year from our friends in the commit consortium, which did this phase two study.
This picture makes it look like it's a randomized study.
It's really a two cohort study of iber, DARA.
It's a post-transplant consolidation versus iber, DARA, Kyprolis post-transplant consolidation,
followed by iber maintenance as a single agent.
And the primary endpoint of this study is also conversion from MRD positivity to MRD
negativity at six months.
So we will hear about that particular endpoint at ASH this year.
One interesting, I think, thing about this study is that, you know, we'll be hearing
a lot more about this study in the next couple of weeks.
We'll be hearing a lot more about this study in the next couple of weeks.
But I think the thing about this study is that DARA or CD38 antibody exposure as part
of induction is permitted but not required.
And so my feeling is it may be a little bit difficult to know what this combination is
adding to what we would consider best induction if it turns out, I don't know the answer to
this, we're not part of this consortium, but if a significant number of patients were
not DARA exposed during induction, you're going to see extraordinary results.
And so my parting thoughts in the last 25 seconds, we know that this is a more potent
cereblon targeting agent than IMIDs, and we're going to learn about these drugs in direct
comparison to IMIDs.
There is currently, at the FDA, they're currently reviewing the data on Iber, DARA, Dex based
on the Iber, DARA, Dex.
And so we're going to learn about these drugs in direct comparison to IMIDs.
And so my parting thoughts in the last 25 seconds, we know that this is a more potent
the Excalibur relapsed refractory myeloma study. So this actually may be an approved combination
by the time we have final results from this study. We'll hear about preliminary results at ASH this
year. And then the big question I think that, I mean, most of us are probably wondering after
hearing about all of this, you know, bispecific and CAR-T data is, you know, is this, how relevant
is this going to be in an era when we're now moving towards things like BCMA bispecifics
in combination with the CD38? Can this kind of a combination be relevant in that era? And I would
say, you know, if you can't beat it, maybe join it. There is also mechanistic, you know, reason
to think that ibertamide may help Bispecific activity as well. And that may be the
future path for maintenance therapy with cell mods. That's it. Thanks.